I saw a viral video of like this girl
she's at Starbucks and then I don't know
if she worked there or not but then the
guy's like yeah your boyfriend's been
coming every day in the drive-through
with another woman hater and she's in
the now she's they got her in the
drive-through and she here she's like oh
can I help you and he's like hey baby do
you want anything and then they pull up
and she's like she's like so mad and she
has like water and whipped cream and she
leans in and she's like there it is
right there she's like hi and she throws
the water right there you want extra
cream she sprays it oh wow but here's
the thing about it the dude
the way he's acting I was like this is
fake chin has a good radar for this
because I always think that was the real
just the way I was like oh the dude's
not they do he's a bad actor let's see
what is this is this the full thing
because it starts when she's throwing
the ice
this just this is just uh the the intro
but they showed up oh gosh yeah that's a
hook here I've seen too much verse 48 I
can just smell this stuff out the other
thing is it's ice water instead of hot
coffee because she was really pissed
it'd be hot coffee he asked for water so
she's like nah but it don't matter you
get what I'm with you man that's what
I'm saying is like you go I like this
this is really interesting seeing people
in the wild be crazy and then you go the
way the guy was like babe it's not what
you think I was like oh you're terrible
yeah yeah yeah just don't say anything
just don't say anything yeah
girl what is she oh I can already tell
his fate yeah
oh yeah oh that's him girl oh my God
this is already fake right Jen okay am I
right the Starbucks what can I get you
oh and she just knows what to say about
like why is she wearing the outfit like
I think she works there
if she works there it's his girlfriend
he wouldn't go to that one
so that's like the
God sometimes it's just like
a wave dude also she's way too hot to be
working at Starbucks
can I take your order skip to the end
where she like season gets mad because
then you can really
like how bad this guy is acting well
it's not what you think
he's gonna do some reason why is he
British you're not throwing hot coffee
it's a banana loaf Adam
man hi hi
oh so bad so bad no wait no wait for
sure some extra whip Drive Away dude I'm
Gonna Leave the window drive away oh
there I am that's cool
um what I don't I don't like that video
and uh it's fake
Yeah Christmas
it was immediate yeah
Eric was done for a little bit and then
figured out and that's fine
you were on the fence honestly Brendan
would still believe it if we didn't
bring it up